[Music]
on the back-office perhaps we can even
create a net new capability for HR where
we collect feedback on our colleagues
and employees as they do their work and
we can collate that we can just ping
that information to a bot and collate
that information as we approach the
review cycle so these are these are ways
that chat BOTS are actually being used
today okay so hopefully hopefully you
would agree with some of these use cases
so next I want to go through a framework
that might help developers and
executives think about chat box chat
BOTS so first I want to just explain
what the different axes represent so on
the y-axis you have the domain where you
start with closed domain chat BOTS that
handle one task or are very specific to
one one thing versus open domain chat
bots which ostensibly can talk about
anything under the Sun so it's almost a
philosophical notion in a way and then
on the modeling front along the x axis
you see retrieval based BOTS versus
generative based BOTS and so retrieval
based BOTS retrieve pre-canned responses
or they retrieve information from a
database while generative bots have
actually learned something about the
data that it was trained on and they're
actually generating text or perhaps you
might say generating speech is a
generative process but let's go through
these one quadrant at a time and try to
understand a couple examples so in the
first quadrant
let's take ordering a pizza as an
example this is pretty straightforward
there are only so many ways that you can
order a pizza there are only so many
different toppings that you can put on
it has to be delivered somewhere and so
the point here is that it's it's closed
domain it's a pretty well-defined task
that needs to that needs to occur and
it's retrieval based because these are
well-defined conversations and we can
retrieve an answer to everything that
the user says moving along the x axis
toward something slightly more complex
you have a generative model and so you
may have heard about google duplex
announced at Google i/o a couple weeks
or months back and this is using mostly
machine learn
deep learning and what it's doing is
it's Google duplex is able to make
restaurant reservations and hair
appointment bookings for you and it's
also able to do this in a very dynamic
way so if you heard some of the phone
conversations you heard about how
dynamic it was in being able to book
that for you so I'd consider that a
generative process but it's closed
domain because just because it's able to
make a restaurant reservation for me
does not mean that it can help me
assemble my IKEA furniture and then in
the lower left hand corner this is a bit
of a thought experiment and so I hope
you'll you know hope I can convince you
that this is actually impossible and the
idea here is that something that's
retrieval based cannot be open domain
and the idea here is that you can't
anticipate everything that the user is
going to ask you and anticipate every
response that you would have to provide
for any conversation right open domain
really means just that we can talk about
anything and so I hope I don't offend
anybody by using expert systems here as
an example because the idea of hind
expert systems is to encode information
about the world and then be able to
reason about that and use that in a
productive way but there's always
something that's not encoded in the
database now to make the point really
clear so perhaps I go to fathom and say
hey can you get me the bumblebee cat gif
and in the bot says I don't think I've
seen that one and I say you had you
never have the latest ones you never
have the latest cat gifs and it
apologizes because you can't possibly
keep up with everything that a user
might ask for or every conversation that
could take place so hopefully that makes
the point clear and then moving on from
there is something that I think a lot of
people in this room and and perhaps at
all the research conferences are
interested in which is artificial
general intelligence or AGI this is the
hardest and this is where research is
taking place and this would involve a
generative model a generative base bot
that's open domain now we don't really
know how to imbibe machines with the
same qualities that humans have
we're very deft taking new information
incorporating that into our knowledge
and an understanding of the world and
then in using that in new and innovative
ways and for any non-native
english-speakers here maybe you've never
heard the word deft before but you can
probably already start to make some
predictions that it means in a clever or
skillful way and it's this quality that
we don't know how to encode into
machines yet where you take something
you've never encountered before you
reason about it and you extend your
understanding of the world okay and so
an example of this for any Isaac Asimov
fans out there is Robby the Robot and so
what we're talking about is the
positronic brain and I say that with a
little tongue-in-cheek but but yeah this
would be an idea of something that's
artificially generally intelligent so
just to be clear this is where fathom
bot sits you might argue that something
like Google or any kind of search based
system is more open domain but I think
that needs to be reserved for only the
most advanced systems okay so hopefully
this is helpful for again both
developers and business thinkers alike
and thinking about what capabilities
they need to build into their next chat
bot okay so the bottom line here is bots
are really powerful in well-defined
domains we're still figuring out how to
extend them to many different tasks
now the second section is around how
BOTS are being built today so as
promised we just talked about some of
the use cases and now we'll talk a bit
about how BOTS are actually being built
but first I think we can go ahead and do
a demo ok so this is the fathom bot and
so we can start by saying hey fathom and
we'll get what we'll get back is a
response to kind of corral users and
start to educate people about how they
can use the bot and what it is useful
for I think it's important to educate
users but they're definitely going to
test your BOTS and you're going to get
questions like how old are you
and bought yours I'm just a kid and then
you'll get questions like can you get
smarter
yes but it depends on how much PwC
invests this is currently under active
development and then you'll probably
want to do something more useful like
search for one of your colleagues
profiles so let's take Adrian boda as an
example and this is actually his profile
so please don't spam him Adrian's
actually a really nice guy and so then
we may want to retrieve some information
about one of our clients or a company
and so we can search for alphabet and we
can pull back that company card not sure
if the Internet's slow here
there we go so if we wanted to we could
then click into that that company's
profile and I think the end state of
something like this would to be able to
would be to reason about that
information so what projects is adrianne
on or what projects do we have going on
with alphabet right now and so that
would be the end State and this uses
some mild machine learning and I'll
explain that when we get back to the
slides but now I want to show you some
more explicit machine learning that
we've used so if we engage the FAQ model
I'll show you how we're and I should be
clear that we've just engaged a certain
intent and I'll explain that when we're
talking about building these BOTS but
maybe we have a question that you might
find in an FAQ sheet and so what we
might ask about is CEO action on
diversity and inclusion because PwC has
been really focused on this year our CEO
has been really like front and center on
this and so what you see is that we're
matching on a number of similar
questions and answers in our question
and answer base and so the idea here is
that we can directly address users
questions without having to have them
click around in the search portal and so
this is using machine learning we've
matched on this question it gives you
the answer sites its source and then
this is really an artifact of
development but it just gives you this
notion of there is a a goodness of fit
or a goodness of match that you can
discern how how confident you are in
putting forward the answer so I'll
mention that when I talk about
thresholds but what I'm really excited
to show you guys today is something that
I think really moves the user experience
and if I do a general search for
something related to international
tariffs because that's making a lot of
headlines lately what it's going to do
is it's going to go and retrieve a bunch
of articles from the fathom database
it's not able to connect to the fatum
database I think you ever try
hmm sorry you guys what's the first rule
of live demos don't do them I'll give it
one more try but I don't want to belabor
the point because I'll talk a bit more
about it later in the presentation I'm
also thinking that this is public right
now and I'm wondering if there are
people in the audience or remotely that
are actually hitting the spot and just
overloading it right now so I thought
that was a possibility I was just
testing this before I came up here and
let's try it one last time no well
apologies for that so what I was going
to try to show was the ability to do a
general search we retrieve some
documents and then we ask a follow-up
question about that documents and so
this uses a machine comprehension model
and so I'll talk a bit more about that
as we move through the presentation so I
think with that we should probably just
move back to the slides thank you okay
so a bit about what you just saw these
are the four things that you're gonna
have to solve for no matter what bought
that you're building and so this is a
bit of a conceptual framework and I
think it's helpful for any developer to
to understand so starting with intent
detection what I'll do when I when I go
through these slides is I'll talk a bit
about the challenge that we're talking
about a bit about show you an example
and then talk about a few solutions
using vendor solutions or open source
solutions if that's more your speed so
for this example the intent detection is
what is the user want so if we're
looking for the whether it's just that
the intent is to get the whether if you
look at this example on the screen info
on Adrian boda is intent classification
where you're trying to determine what
the user is looking for and it's not a
company search it's not a people search
but it's a it's not a company search or
a general search it's a people search
and so if you think about that it's just
a text classification task and you can
use your favorite text classification
pipeline TF
to random forest or if you have more
data you might go with something more
sophisticated like an LS TM or if you
don't want to build something like that
you can use something rules ish based
approach like dialog flow or the NLP API
which hopefully I can explain on the
next slide so the second challenge is
going to be entity extraction what
information do we need to extract from
the text in order to be able to fulfill
the request and so what we see here is
and then one sub bullet on that is can
we rely on dialogue flow for proper
nouns so people places and things like
that because you have to train the the
dialogue flow agent to be able to detect
these proper nouns and it's very
difficult to enumerate all of the
employees at your company in dialogue
flow and so here are two ways that this
may go off the rails in the first
example somebody might say info on
Adrian boda and maybe you get the intent
which is to query for a person but you
don't extract the entity which is
underlined in red and so one solution
here is to use follow ups so you might
say hey I think you're looking for a
people of people search but I didn't get
the name so what what name are you
looking for and then you can proceed
that way when the user provides the name
another situation is where you don't
have a lot of context at all and you're
you're working with proper now and
something like alphabet you might not
get the intent or the entity and so one
solution here is to use something like
the NLP API so you head out to the NLP
API determine what entity was extracted
and if it's an organization you now have
the company that you're searching for as
well as the intent which is a company
search and so what we're talking about
here is named entity recognition models
or any are models and dialogue flow does
this natively the NLP API does this
natively but if you're more into the
open source scene the Stanford NER
tagger or the source Pacey or any number
of open source tools will allow you to
allow you to accomplish this task now
the next challenge is state management
the idea here is where are we in the
conversation and anytime you have a
conversation that takes on more than
turn in other words the user asks a
question like and by the way this was
what I was going to try to show was
where you have a search like
international tariffs it finds some
documents and asks do you have any
additional questions I say yes and then
we asked about I don't know what are the
implications of International tariffs on
manufacturing and then it will you know
give you a direct answer now I also want
to mention that machine learning hasn't
really been able to solve this yet and
so I'll link you to a paper here called
end to end task completion neural
dialogue systems where they attempt to
use a fully differentiable deep learning
model to be able to solve the task of
booking a movie ticket and it's you know
with mixed results so I guess that
brings me into the solutions dialog flow
is terrific for this and architecting
these conversational flows and then
another thing that I'll mention is [ __ ]
or some sort of external store you can
imagine interacting with your user
across time and across multiple
platforms and so you seem you need some
notion of cache or persisting that users
profile across interactions and then the
final thing is hopefully machine
learning will make some advances in this
in the near questionmark future the
final challenge to be solved for any bot
assuming it's informatics retrieval
based right so the distinction I made
earlier would be would be retrieval
based versus generative based models
when you think about information
retrieval there are two sources of
information one is structured sources
the other is unstructured and so
structured sources are things like CSV
files you can think of them like sequel
queries or API calls but unstructured
sources require a bit more deep learning
machine learning data science and that's
the stuff that I get excited about and
so what you see here is an unstructured
text document and that was really the
focus of our project which which was to
retrieve information from unstructured
text sources so similar to the way that
I was showing the FAQ model were able to
answer questions as such and so some
solutions here are
to use machine learning models and deep
learning models or even something more
naive like a tf-idf model if you have
less data and then some of the easier
ones or sequel queries and api queries
and I'll also call out Q a net because
that was the model that we had running
in our fathom bot which is a machine
comprehension model
Google published that paper a few months
back and I think it's still number one
on the squad leader board and I'll
explain a bit more about all that in
just a moment so this is probably why a
lot of you guys attended this talk and
so I want to take a moment to just talk
through the architecture and sort of
what this actually looks like on Google
cloud starting with the user in the
upper right corner the user is trying to
interact with dialog flow they make a
hop to App Engine which makes the call
to dialogue flow and dialogue flow
evaluates the users request determines
how to route it determines what
information needs to be extracted out of
that and then sends that to what I call
the broker which is this guy right in
the middle and this is a bit of a
Russian doll we have a Python flask app
running in docker running on kubernetes
and so I'm sure this is a pretty common
design pattern for some of the folks in
this room but what I really like is the
elasticity of this and so the idea is
here is that you get all the benefits of
the horizontal scaling is more users
come online and so the idea I guess I
should be clearer and say that the
brokers responsibility is to ping all
these different API is to go out and do
fulfillment as it's called in the
dialogue flow documentation and so one
source of fulfillment is the PWC
database where we're retrieving some of
that you know information about our
colleagues and companies and clients and
then we also have some GPU enabled
instances running on kubernetes so we've
got some tensor flow models running on
GPU enabled instances for some of these
tasks like information retrieval
question-answer models and then finally
you can in you can use external storage
like [ __ ] or you might even hack it
with something like cloud storage where
your
retrieving information based on
conversation IDs so this is in short
what you know what what is architected
on the cloud platform and a couple tips
that might be might be useful to
somebody that's going down this road
once you understand what dialogue flow
does I would encourage you to look at
the Python dialogue flow package once
you really understand what dialogue flow
does you can and should script just
about everything with respect to bot
creation and updates g-cloud is
obviously a great tool it's your friend
you can use it to to build these these
kubernetes clusters you can basically
use it to build your entire
infrastructure and so I would definitely
encourage that to be your source of
documentation versus you know creating
documentation sheets where somebody has
to go into the user interface and click
around it's just too prone to error as
we found establish a robust testing
framework so this becomes a quite
complex system what happens is you've
got the you've got a noisy input coming
from users dialogue flows evaluating
that you're trying to understand how
dialogue flow is going to behave under
various circumstances and then you're
trying to understand how fulfilment is
going to behave insert under certain
circumstances so you need to really have
like a robust testing framework to
understand where things might be going
off the rails if and when they do and
then finally I'm team docker and
kubernetes I probably don't have to say
much more on that but I just like it as
a development pattern alright so the the
key things here our machine learning is
already pretty present in most chat BOTS
today and GCP has all the necessary
tools to do this so now let's move into
some of the intelligence layer as I was
discussing before with machine learning
and again as promised we've talked about
some use cases we've talked a bit about
how bots are actually built and now
we're gonna talk a bit about how machine
learning is layered into this bot so
these were three information retrieval
tasks that we thought about during this
project and and so what are each of
these in a word
so document retrieval you've got a query
and you're looking for relevant
documents
it's basically what Google does we have
a query like International tariffs we
should be able to retrieve documents at
PwC that are related to this query the
second task question-answering is taking
questions that you might see on an FAQ
document and being able to take a query
and find a similar question or find the
answer to that user's query so an
example would be what should I know
about international tariffs and the
response would be the matched question
so what tariffs have been proposed with
which it was matched to and then
ultimately the user is looking for
something like this like the answer and
then machine comprehension which I think
is the most sophisticated of all these
is where you're answering a user's
question by retrieving a very specific
span of text from some unstructured text
document so an example was and this is
what I wanted to show during the demo
but the query would have been something
like what should manufacturers prepare
for after tariffs tariffs and the
response would be something like higher
material costs so again these were three
of the tasks we focused on the latter
two so question and answering and
machine comprehension so we can double
click into each of those to get a better
sense of how we're actually building
that so question answering there's two
ways to think about it one is question
to question where you're using something
like a tf-idf base model and you can
just measure the cosine similarity
between two vectors and you'll get
something like a match score and the
idea here is you take a question like
this and you match it to all of the
questions that you have in your database
and you look for the best match and then
by default you just have the answer as
your lookup value right so that's
hopefully pretty straightforward now the
other way of thinking about it and this
is often when you have more data and
we've trained models you know with with
hundreds of thousands of examples and
we've seen deep learning models start to
really excel here where you go from a
question to an answer so the user says
something like what should I know about
international tariffs and
the match and you're trying to match to
an answer and so the deep learning model
is going through the answer column now
and trying to match that query to the
appropriate answer and and I think this
is probably obvious for a number of
folks but you might want to cite your
source and any other information that
might be helpful to the user to be able
to do their own further investigation
now the final piece of this talk is
around machine comprehension and I
really like the way that the one of the
co-authors of the squad paper described
it and he says it's the ability to read
a piece of text and then answer
questions about it and this is really
challenging for machines and to be clear
the squad paper refers to the Stanford
question-answering dataset which has
become the de-facto benchmark for
machine comprehension models and so QA
net as I mentioned earlier I think is
still ranked number one for that data
set and so again to be abundantly clear
we're talking about selecting an answer
span from a provided text passage and so
if we look at the picture on the right
which is taken from the squad paper you
see there's a passage these are
Wikipedia articles and then the users
have posed a bunch of questions against
that article and they've also
highlighted the answer and so the first
question is what precipitation to fall
answer being gravity and you can see
that it's listed up above and so that
should also tell you how these datasets
are structured where you have a passage
query and an answer and with that we can
build machine learning models to take in
passages and questions and hopefully put
forward what it thinks is the most
likely answer and so for anyone that
thinks they've solved the task of
machine comprehension I would encourage
you to take a look at this question here
which says which technology was
developed most recently in to us the
answer is obviously a the cellular
telephone but for the guy on the left
this is a difficult task we don't really
know how to imbibe machine learning
models with this notion of common sense
or
real-world reasoning and the information
is there we just don't really know how
to encode it into these machine learning
models whereas it's very trivial for the
guys on the right which is a picture
from the movie Dumb and Dumber and I'll
leave you with one little nugget here if
you're interested in these topics I
really enjoy listening to a podcast
called data skeptic hosted by a guy
named Kyle Pollak and he did an episode
called the imitation game where he
interviews some folks from the Allen
Institute and talks about this data set
and this task
fresh off the press
last month squad the the squad team
released a second data set and I think
they're addressing what I think is a
pretty important problem which is to
abstain when presented with a question
that cannot be answered in other words
if the models not confident enough or
couldn't find the answer in the provided
text passages we need to know that we're
not confident enough to put forward the
answer and right now I'm having to use
things like thresholds to be able to
determine if I've got enough information
to answer the question or not or I'm
confident enough to answer that question
so for any practitioners out there you
know that transfer learning can only
take you so far
Squad was from the Wikipedia domain I'm
working in the PWC domain so
transferring a model trained on
Wikipedia will only take me so far for
PwC labeling data is expensive so as
much as I'd love $20,000 to go out to
Mechanical Turk and label a bunch of
data I'm not gonna get it proof for that
and so we need to think about how we
generate data and either a
semi-supervised or a fully unsupervised
way and so what I want to do what I want
to share here is something that we would
be exploring if we had more time this
paper is called sin net and if you look
at the one two and three on the screen
here the idea here is that we can take
the squad data set we've got the
passages the questions and the answers
and we can train a model to generate
interesting questions and answers given
the passage and we know what those
questions and then and answers are
because we have labeled data so once we
train a model to do that we can feed in
pwc documents and take those passages
and generate
questions and answers in the PWC domain
and then you close the training loop by
going back to the machine comprehension
model and fine tuning that model on a
combination of the squad data and the
PWC data to be able to bring that model
into the PWC domain and perform a little
bit better so these are the things that
you have to think about on a day-to-day
to be able to actually get these machine
learning models up and running so I
think hopefully that was convincing that
machine learning models can and should
improve information retrieval especially
for unstructured documents so some final
considerations here what data can you
collect so for the FAQ documents we had
to round up all these FAQ sheets and
then parse out those documents I extract
out the questions the answers and I
think we wound up with something like
20,000 question-answer pairs that we can
then train our machine learning models
with I just talked a couple slides back
about the need to generate or label data
and circumcircle stances these are some
things that you'll have to think about
and then how can we improve the quality
of our results from user feedback so for
open to capturing user feedback was this
useful or not how do we then close the
model training loop and incorporate that
into our model improve results on the
user front how confident are we that we
have the right answer and this comes
back to the notion of fresh holding
where you have a probability score
associated with a lot of these models
and that should be tuned to determine
the number of false positives and also
the amount of volume that you can handle
for incoming queries be clear about what
the bot can and can't do so when I first
started interacting with the bot it said
I'm helpful for people queries company
queries general searches and so you kind
of have to coach users because I think
the expectations are set very high and I
think you're definitely set up to
disappoint users if you're not clear
enough consider edge cases so your your
users will try to push the bots to its
limits and you just want to understand
how it's going to behave in those edge
cases and this is for a number of data
scientists out in the room I think we
all do a good job defining measures
intrinsic evaluation so accuracy score
recall that kf1 scores exact match all
that fun stuff but we also need to think
about measures of extrinsic evaluation
so how have we moved the needle for the
business in terms of user time save
number of clicks reduced to find a piece
of information or potentially even
revenue so if I've done my job well this
is where you are we've talked about some
use cases how bots are being built today
and a bit about the intelligence layer
that concludes this talk and I'm happy
to take questions at this time thank you
[Music]